Hey guys, welcome back to Spectrum
We would like to thank the Try Guys for being such awesome guests in this episode
and we would like to remind you that
if you want to participate by either suggesting prompts for future episodes, or
Predicting what the cast answers will be in the video. You can follow us on Instagram and get involved that way.
So check us out and enjoy the episode!
(Z) Views can't be all that matters because if that was the case
Then the greatest artists of our generation would be vine compilations which are great, they're dope.
I'm Keith Habersberger. I'm Ned Fulmer. I'm Zach Kornfeld. I'm Eugene Lee Yang
(Simultaneously) and I am a Try Guy.
(K) I always look forward to finding out things that I don't already know.
(N) Not looking forward to answering personal questions but really, who is?
(Z) I just hope that this is a chance for you to get to know us more deeply and intimately than ever before.
(E) I look forward to creating the most insane chaotic Jubilee spectrum video in the history of this channel.
(Simultaneously) Hiii....!
(E) That's pretty, pretty fucking stupid (N) That was pretty good, pretty good
(Jubilee) Yeah. This is our first prompt
Three...two...one...go
(N) I guess says the odd man out like I'll try anything once. (E) No,I'm going back here. (Z) Ooh!
(N) You can't be in the middle. (K) Can't be there
(E) Oh
Well, I don't want to murder anybody. (Z) Well, you've never tried murdering someone
(E) I'm just oh, so I can try to murder someone but not actually- (Z) You'd fail (E) we always associate trying with positivity
(N) I mean, I guess I didn't think about murdering someone as being part of the- (Z) You guys see that Ned Fulmer is a murderer!
(N) No, I'm not a strong murder
(Zach) In in the try guys. I'm the cute one. I'm the neurotic Jewish one
I talk with my hands a lot, uses a lot of pop-culture references when they're not necessary and
Pushes probably more of our absurdist content
Three...two...one...go...
(K) Well a lot of semantics there yeah. Yeah. All right, (E) what are you doing? You know, you're on this side (K) I think here
(Z) That movie is so
Objectively abysmal that it transcends to a new realm of being as a modern cinematic masterpiece
So I'm standing here to say that I stand for cats
(K) Is Pizza an open-faced sandwich? Is a Taco a sandwich?
(E) If you think a hotdog is a sandwich you are wrong. (Z) And you should unsubscribe from this channel
Aliens... the universe is vast and infinite and ever-expanding. There's got to be life somewhere.
(K) And look at the lobster
What a creature the lobster is how can this earth have both humans and lobsters?
(Z) How do you know that we're not aliens?
I
Don't
(E) Yeah... (Z) I watched my prom date hook up with someone else. (N) Yeah same. (Z) Yeah it hurt...
It's still it still hurts
(K ) My prom date for one of mine was
Dating someone else at the time, but the prom is what changed it and got us to start dating.
So I'm sort of- (Z) You're the villain!
(K) but we didn't make out we just fell in love
(Z) A little bit of poop you've probably eaten before... (E) I don't care much for brownies (Z) But it's the tastiest one in the world, Eugene
Don't you want to say that you had the best... (E) But like I don't really care I eat a** so I don't care about poop
(everyone laughs) (K) That's what were taking about
(E) Yah we're just talking about eating a**
I'm way over here
I'm the Try Guy known for his greatest hits of not being white or straight
I'm also probably best known for being the one with the darkest opinions and the least optimistic view on life
Everything is going slowly to shit
(everyone chuckles)
Three...two...one...go
(K)That's tough, you know, it changes all the time
(N) You guys felt us move this way and didn't want to seem like an asshole
(Z) I think that our strength is that there is not a standout,
we are truly an ensemble and we're all great in different ways. And that's hopefully what makes us fun to watch
(E) I don't know. I think Keith's the best Try Guy
(K) Okay
Alright cool...
We all have like
fans that feel that maybe they like me the most or they like Zach the most or like Ned or Eugene the most but
Our dynamic speaks to lots of people in that way
But they still come back for the show more than they come back for our individual products.
Gotta be honest though it feels really cool over here
(Z) Should we try it?
(K) You should give it a shot. (N) Try some confidence? (K) You should give it a shot
It feels good to think that maybe you are like...the best (N) I am the best Try Guy...
Uh, no, it just never crossed my mind. I think it were yeah, we're just an ensemble
Three...two...one...go...
(K) Mm. I'll take this one. (Z) I mean no, but... (K) right it's like I don't miss it
But there were so many awesome people that work there. They really helped to build that video
Department and it was a really magical time
it was before Facebook even had video and we were like
Experimenting and it was really cool and it felt like you were on the ground floor of something
Exciting for a whole cultural revolution of how content existed
but I'm way happier now
(N) But the question was do you miss BuzzFeed?
I mean, I don't miss BuzzFeed at all. Sure those early days were great
But now we're in the early days of building something new and exciting with our awesome creative people on our own staff for ourselves
And that's way better. (Z) Yeah. (K) Yeah, it is way better... just a sentimental boy
Sometimes and I think about, we met there, you know, so that's that's you know, I got to acknowledge it
(Z) I mean, I don't miss middle school, but like yeah, there are people that I liked there
(N) I interpret miss to mean like, would you like to go back? (K) Okay, no I don't want to go back
I'm the food guy of the group, I'm the goofy one. I do a lot of silly fast food videos a lot of absurd impromptu singing and
I probably try to avoid responsibility the most
Three...two...one...go...
(N) If Keith is worried about his health then I guess I should be worried about his health (K) Oh somewhat, you know, it's a lot of eating...
Really...
Poor quality meats, and it creates a lot of stomach stretching
(N) Well that sounds bad
(E) A year ago, I'd be here
But today I think maybe I'm over here because I know what you do in your lifestyle now, you're much healthier in your lifestyle
(K) Yeah, once those videos started becoming popular it was about the same time I decided I shouldn't be so unhealthy, so, you know
I showed up today with a green smoothie and I'm...
Working out two to three times a week which I never did before, and also when I shoot those videos to try to work out
a lot the days before so my metabolism is better... (N) And I think that you are so
hyperly aware of what's going into your body at other times maybe because of it that
Maybe eating all that garbage is making you a better person
(K) Yeah maybe... (Z) Cuz you ate like shit before (K)I did eat terribly before (Z) And honestly
I think like eating garbage every day is probably worse than eating it all concentrated for one video
(E) Yeah, you know maybe the videos have made him a healthier person
(K) You've convinced me!
(general agreement noises and happiness)
(Z) You should eat garbage too
Three...two...one..go...
(E) Really? (K) It is an achievement to have two videos a week on your channel for almost two years
Even if some of the videos aren't as good as others, (N) that's right
(E)That's kind of like saying you're proud of your shi**y kid
(Z) When you're independent, every video is a triumph
(E) No, even though I'm happy that we have two videos a week but I'm not proud of every video. (Everyone) Mmhm
(K) Well, I don't think these guys care that much for The Barkscheler. It's a short-lived series where I rated people's dogs
(Z) I made a video where I watched every Dolan twins video thought it was gonna be a big hit...
It wasn't
(N) I thought it was a good idea rather than not release videos in January when we went on a Christmas vacation to release
compilation videos
They were both very average, people saw right through it
I'm a Tr-... oh it's just audio I can look wherever I want! I'm the one that always talks about his wife and his baby
I'm the quote/unquote responsible one, but really?
That can be quite irresponsible
Three...two...one...go...
(Z) Can't go to Disneyland without taking about 40 photos. (N) Yeah. I'm not like Justin Bieber
(Z) No, dude you're just like Justin Bieber. (N) Thanks man, (E) Hey you're wearing the same sweatshirt color that he wears in
That song that's not that great. (K) Yummy? (E) Yummy. (K) Is that what it's called? (E) Is that about what I think it's about?
(Z) Yesss
(E) I'm here because I see growth. (K) Well, I mean we're internet famous. I used to say we were fame-ish because you're famous to a huge
Demographic, but then there's other demographics that are like completely locked out
So sometimes like kids will come up and then their parents are like, who's that?
Who are you and it's it's weird to deal with someone who's like super excited and someone who's almost being like
Condescending because they haven't heard of you.
(N) Like I go to an Ed Sheeran concert
I get recognized a lot. I go to an NFL game
you know, I can usually coast by with the hat and
A Jersey and you know enjoy the game
Three...two...one...go...
(Z) Considering I'm the most insecure too I'm saying somewhat disagree because on the whole I know that psychologically for every
One negative comment you read it's the power of a thousand positive comments. So to do anything in the public eye
You need to learn to just shake it off and and not take it to heart cuz yeah, it's just bogus
(N) I mean I do what you guys are saying, but it still affects me
there was an episode of Try DIY that we almost took down because there was many negative comments about our
significant others...
(E) I...um
Don't talk about it
but I constantly get comments about my race and my sexuality...
and I've constantly gotten comments about that in person before I was even an entertainer
So as strong as I need to appear which I think is a requirement as a representative of that race and sexuality
I'm still like the sensitive to a kid who got made fun of for it
I'm sensitive to it because I have to make sure everything I do is
Empowering and not making me look weak. (Z) I guess in reality. I am probably over there
I just know that this is where I need to be (E) I wish I could be over there
(K) Yeah, this is my active choice of how I deal with it is to not let it bother me... (N) yeah, we're supposed to be all the way over there
(K)Yeah, (E) So maybe your feet are here and our hands are over there.
(Z) Do you wanna make a bridge together? (E) Yeah, let's make a bridge
Wow, yeah, come on. We're... Yahhh
Three...two...one...go...
(E) Gah...I'm such an artsy f*ck I'm sorry
(K) I would understand any answer in this prompt
They matter because they're pretty much a direct relation to your earnings and since we have a company with other people that rely on
that company to be successful for their income as well, and it's
exciting when a video like starts getting views really fast in that first day because you feel
Accomplished, because it means it's resonating with people. It's spreading
you put good in the world and (N) it's gotten that much farther the message to spread that much further
Look if you counts didn't matter at all we wouldn't be here
maybe you wouldn't even be watching this video because this company
wouldn't exist
(K) There are often times where you do not accurately predict the success of the video
And sometimes that's frustrating because there are videos the work really really hard on you think they're really awesome and then they perform ok
And then there videos that you you know
You sit down you eat a table full of fast food and it crushes, your like well, this isn't the best message
(Z) Views can't be all that matters because if that was the case
Then the greatest artists of our generation would be vine compilations, which are great. They're dope
You want to hopefully find the middle ground. How do you make something that is great and meaningful and deep and
Specific that also can find it's niche and thrive and grow. (N) Yeah, but if we were getting 10 times as many views
but we thought all of our content was very shallow and hollow and not
Enriching the world. I think we would feel pretty bad about ourselves
(Z) Like we have videos that have 8, 10, 20 million views. There's one video I made that has
One or two million views and that's the video that I got talked to about more than anything. So it's not, it's not that direct
Three...two...one...go...
(K) Well, it's not that simple
you know like
Letting someone join that that implies that the show is just talent
Based and it's not just talent based. It's, it's directorial. It's produced. It's really well thought out it's based on a lot of
Statistics and measuring over like six years... I could be on either somewhat, you know
(N)I meant, joining to me is like there's some you know random person here with like a yellow hoodie
Like hey, it's Karl
We've been doing it for so long
I don't think we're ever gonna we'd have to call it something different like the new Try Guys
(Z) You can never say never, like yes the four of us
No, it's probably hard to imagine that dynamic changing, but I think it's inevitable for our growth that in the next
5-10 years
Yeah
I think it's going to benefit us to
expand the cast and allow people with different perspectives and different backgrounds to try things that will deepen and enrich our videos and
Allow us to grow in different directions
Three...two...one...go...
(E) I'm kidding
(N) We hang out on weekends we go on vacations together
(E) But Zach and Keith are the best friends. (Z) Yeah, you guys better better step it up
(K) Well I mean Ned obviously has a son
Eugene is also like normally got some gala he's going to so he's harder to hang out with on a whim and
Zach and I are pretty not busy outside work...
They were all my groomsmen in my wedding
Because yeah, they're some of the most important people in my life.
(Z) And I've been forcefully told that for my eventual wedding I'm gonna have to do the same
(K) Yep
The nature of the show that we do, it like, friendship is a result of the
Experiments because you're doing all these new things together. You're very vulnerable around one another in like every
Context so doing that 200 times with the same people
The best friend boot camp you could ever have (Z) We're actually delusional we're not friends,
but the experiences make us think that we're friends...
Three...two...one...go...
(E) Yeah, I think it's made me a better friend and I think it's made me more open
I was shaped by a lot of more formative experiences with my background that
Really pulled me from dark places and I think that this has just been the most successful
friendship I've ever had but it certainly hasn't
I don't think it's constructed the core of my character. (Z) Has It made you a happier person
(E) Yeah, it's made me somewhat happier. Yeah, I think, but I...
(N) Has it made you like babies a little bit more...? (E) Your baby has made me like it a little bit more
(K) I agree it has made me a better person
But I think there are probably ways in which our work ethic to this company has maybe made me a worse person to
Some people in my life, right?
Like as we have become more busy my time with other friendships or relationships
Has certainly dwindled a bit and I feel bad about that sometimes.
(N) I think we're really lucky that we get to do so much stuff that
I never would have otherwise done. Yeah, I think that's made me a better person for sure
(Z) Yeah, if you measure a life in experiences, this is the single greatest thing that could have ever happened to us
And on just a much more personal level. It's it's made me more confident and secure with who I am. It's made me happier
It's allowed I think my personality to to thrive and flourish where before being on the internet. I, I think I was a very
Insecure, closed-off person and somehow subjecting myself to strangers in the world made me a much happier guy
(E) Nice...
(Z) And I made three
(In harmony) best friends
(E) Oh god... You're going to end it on that
(N) I love it! (E) Okay...
And a dab callback, don't forget that (E) Don't dab
(Z) Yeah, I'm deeply offended (K) About the cats one? (Z) Yeah... Ned hasn't even seen the movie
(E) I haven't seen it either...(Z) He's saying he can speak... (realizes what Eugene said) wait I'm sorry, what? (K) I know were supposed to see it this weekend...
We didn't (E) look cats is not a good movie. It's a bad good. Yeah, if you know, it's bad good and you are very high